when you go with Smosh and you're doing
all this stuff are you making more money
being with Smosh or do you feel like are
there taking a percentage and you're
making less and working harder well okay
so let's see I mean it's kind of hard to
say because when we sold Smosh there
wasn't too much money to be made on the
internet yet in 2011 uh so as we were
six years deep we made zero dollars for
the first two years we sold uh we didn't
have ads yeah but we we mostly made
money up to that point uh hand packaging
uh merge merch and selling it like
shipping it out of the local post office
packaging in my bedroom that was the way
we afforded equipment and to pay for
um some very small production things and
then uh finally uh Google we're one of
the first 10 channels after Google
purchases YouTube where they enable
monetization
um and then we're able to start paying
for more things and then uh I had this
little fear that YouTube was gonna
potentially collapse because they were
changing a lot of things with the way
that they were displaying content and um
then also defy came in and was like Hey
not only can we help insure you for at
least I think we did like a four-year
contract at that point uh but we can
also provide tons and tons of resources
for you to do all these dreams that you
have and um you know I was coding the
website myself at that point and uh
because I was just a kid that taught
myself how to do all these things on the
computer and um I was like you know what
I would like to not focus on programming
this website anymore or dealing with uh
the server crashing in your partner did
your partner know how to code no no that
was that was all me
um so I was like one we're gonna sell
this company we're gonna take all that
off my hands well I'll still be able to
hopefully accomplish all the dreams that
I had for this website becoming a place
like
um I wanted to feel like a little mini
social media Network that was only for
people that were into the types of
things types of Comedy that we were into
um but you know spoiler that never ended
up happening because it wasn't as
lucrative at least as quickly lucrative
as I think that they had hoped for
um but yeah then then they purchased and
we became salaried employees and we were
guaranteed a salary for those four years
that was incrementally becoming a little
bit bigger of a number each year that we
were there and
um it was exciting because we had
guaranteed money and I think growing up
feeling like I came from an environment
that was so chaotic I think I wanted
stability and that was part of the that
was probably the biggest reason that I
ended up ultimately making the choice
aside from lots of different people
telling us that it was the best decision
we could ever make and I was 23 at the
time I think now old enough to be able
to to zoom out and see the potential
downsides to all of it but I didn't know
any better and
um decided that stability was the most
important thing
um Looking Back Now I don't think that I
would have made this same choice
um I might have still sold but I think
that I would have retained ownership in
some way you would have made a better
deal I would have made a much better
deal
um and was it yours or where did you
guys split it was it 50 50. it was 50 50
between Ian and I but like I said it was
it was just stock so no but anything
that you were making were you making
equal money because you you seem to be
doing more of the work in in as far as
even technically behind the scenes and
things he wants like coding the website
yeah I mean I think that we might have
done like 5248 because I was doing like
slightly more but I didn't mind doing
that stuff because Ian um you know uh
while I was doing more technical things
he was bringing a lot more of the
lightheartedness and comedy
um and writing that I wasn't able to
provide as well so you know we were each
able to focus on our our strong suits
um but yeah we were making a a decent
living off of that you know I was able
to purchase a car and all these things I
never thought that I'd be able to do
and then you it grew into there's a
whole cast of people were they just
employees they weren't Partners exactly
they were just employees
um and then the cast on screen Talent
started growing in about
2015 that was about two years before I
left and it was something that we we did
want we wanted to expand the cast
um because we didn't want to have to be
in everything uh I didn't see that you
know considering that we did not own any
of the company
and that
um
we didn't reap any long-term benefits if
they didn't go public I didn't see the
potential dangers in casting people to
replace that's essentially not that they
were going to replace us entirely but
like you know appear in all the things
and then have me kind of be sitting in
the background I thought that was a
great idea if I owned the company I
think that would have been a great idea
but considering I did not I think that
it was a potentially dangerous plan to
uh you know potentially replace us when
you made the decision to leave was that
uh are you still friends yeah yeah and
we've been getting even more close
lately I think was it contentious at the
beginning it wasn't contentious I think
it was passive you know not necessarily
passive aggressive but very passive we
became friends in sixth grade and I
think that we established a lot of our
communication style at that time and
it's stage sixth grader communication
style for a very long time but we've
just we've been reconnecting a lot
lately and what's he doing he's still
there he's still with Smosh so
um and Smosh is like Rhett and Link now
right yeah yeah so so basically I left
in 2017 when I realized that defy was
running it in ways that I
um not just running the company but also
like running me into the ground with all
the demands that they had for all the
different things that you know we were
required to be a part of
um so I left to do my own thing very
scary time and then a year later defy
shut down they kind of had
um a very dark age period where they had
no owner and then mythical Rhett link
came in and purchased them so now they
uh Smosh is still is owned by a company
but it's now owned by mythical which is
red link yeah yeah so Ian's still there
and Ian's been part of that ride the
entire time do you ever do you miss it I
miss doing Smosh sketches a lot I don't
miss doing a lot of the extra things
that defy through at us to do some of it
I do and it was really interesting but
it's the sketches themselves and I think
that there's this Golden Era probably
about a four-year period which
ironically was after defy purchase even
though I ended up not liking the way
that defy ran things it did take a lot
off my plate and at that time I didn't
know how to do all the things that defy
was helping us do and I think that was
our golden age of like these four years
where our sketches were super tight this
the the script writing I think was was
actually pretty damn good and it it
holds up and I miss doing that I missed
just uh
the the late nights of of laughter
writing a script and just one-upping
each other
[Music]